This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. So this is a little bonus episode of 99% Invisible. And one of the big things we did this year was we released a brand new show inside of a show created and hosted and conceived and reported by Avery Trollman who is here with me in the studio. Yes. And what I want to talk to you about is this was a phenomenon. It was called the fourth best podcast of the year, according to the New Yorker. And so I wanted to talk to you a little bit about the making of it and what you learned
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗马·马斯。这是一期“99%隐形”的小型特别节目。今年我们做的一件大事，就是在节目中推出了一个全新的节目，由埃弗里·特罗尔曼创作、主持、构思并报道，她现在就在录音室里和我在一起。是的。我想和你聊聊的是，这真是一个轰动一时的现象。根据《纽约客》杂志的报道，它被评为年度第四佳播客。所以我想和你聊聊它的制作过程以及你学到了什么
in the process of it, both in terms of the production of it as a show, as a piece of entertainment and information, but also personally how it affected your view of clothing, your view of style, well, that's everything. So first, what was it like to have the show with in a show and how did it feel to be out there as the host? What was it like?
在这个过程中，无论是在节目制作方面，作为一部娱乐和信息作品，还是在个人层面上，它如何影响了你对服装的看法、对风格的看法，这简直是一切。那么首先，拥有一个节目中的节目是什么感觉？作为主持人站在外面感觉如何？那是什么感觉？
Oh, it's so scary, I don't know. You do it. It's scary, isn't it? It's really scary to have your voice out there, especially in this realm where I didn't know anything about it before. And yeah, there was just so much to synthes especially in this realm where I didn't know anything about it before. Right. And yeah, there was just so much to synthesize in this series.
哦，太可怕了，我不知道。你来试试。很可怕，对吧？把你的声音表达出来真的很可怕，特别是在这个领域，我之前对它一无所知。是的，有太多的东西需要综合，特别是在这个领域，我之前对它一无所知。没错。是的，在这个系列中，有太多的东西需要去融会贯通。
I've been working on it for so long. Yeah. I learned so much and it really changed the way I dress and the way I shop entirely. Oh, that's amazing. So what do you mean by that? The funny thing is, I think going into the series, I was like, I am a close person. I am a person who loves close. And then after reporting the series, I am a person who hates close. And I am a person. No, no, no, no, no, I'm a person who loves style and I love fashion. Yeah, but clothes
我为它工作了很长时间。是的。我学到了很多，它彻底改变了我的着装方式和购物方式。哦，太棒了。那你这话是什么意思？有趣的是，我想在进入这个系列时，我是这样想的：“我是一个喜欢衣服的人。我是一个热爱衣服的人。”然后在报道了这个系列之后，我成了一个讨厌衣服的人。我是一个……不，不，不，不，我是一个热爱风格和时尚的人。是的，但是衣服
are tricky. Okay, so explain the nuance here that you're speaking of So as we learned in episode number five of articles of interest about denim the process of making clothes right any kind of clothes is really wasteful. It's pretty shocking and we live in a world where it is so easy to just buy new clothes. And that's what I used to do all the time, not even thinking about it. I think a lot of people who don't consider themselves big shoppers, just here and there occasionally just impulsively buy things from the internet, from a store, and maybe sometimes it fits, and sometimes it's your style, and sometimes it's not, and whatever, then you donate it to the goodwill, and that's good for the goodwill.
真的很棘手。好吧，请解释一下你所说的这种微妙之处。正如我们在关于牛仔布的《兴趣文章》第五集所学到的那样，制作衣服的过程——对，任何种类的衣服——其实都是非常浪费的。这相当令人震惊，我们生活在一个买新衣服如此轻松的世界里。我以前总是这样，甚至都不去想它。我想很多不认为自己是大买家的人，只是偶尔在网上、在商店里冲动购物，有时可能合身，有时是你的风格，有时不是，管他呢，然后你把它捐给古德威尔旧货店，这对古德威尔来说是件好事。
And that is totally how I lived. You're like, you're like, absolved from the consumerism because you know you're gonna donate it, and close are these imminently, donating objects, but that's not enough. It's no, no, because it's really, most clothes end up in landfill anyway. And Goodwill and Salvation Army, these amazing organizations provide this virtuous outlet for us to just continue getting rid of clothes
我完全就是那样生活的。你就好像，你好像从消费主义中解脱出来了，因为你知道你要把它捐掉，衣服就是这种随时可以捐赠的物品，但这还不够。不，不，因为实际上，大多数衣服最终还是会被运往垃圾填埋场。而古德威尔和救世军这些了不起的组织，为我们提供了一个高尚的出口，让我们得以不断地处理掉衣服
and buying new stuff all the time. And we're in the cycle of like, buy, donate, buy, donate, buy, donate, buy, donate, which, you know, it's good to donate your clothes, but it's not the solution for overconsumption. Right. And clothes contribute to 8% of all CO2 emissions in the world. And that's huge. That's a huge output.
并一直在买新东西。我们陷入了买、捐、买、捐、买、捐、买、捐的循环中，你知道，捐衣服是好事，但这不是解决过度消费的方法。没错。而且服装占了世界所有二氧化碳排放量的8%。这是一个巨大的数字。这是一个巨大的输出量。
And we are just consuming too many new things. And so every designer I talk to is like thinking about this, concerned about this, worried about this, and so many people were just like, you need to stop buying clothes. Yeah. Even the people who make the clothes. Yes. Vivian Westwood herself has this whole campaign, she has these shirts that say, buy less on them. I don't know if she's selling them or not, but on her Twitter, there's a video where she's like, I'm making this new collection, but you have got to help because you mustn't buy
而且我们消费的新东西实在是太多了。所以我采访的每一位设计师都在思考这个问题，对此感到关切，对此感到担忧，许多人甚至直言：“你需要停止买衣服。”是的。甚至连制作衣服的人也是如此。是的。薇薇安·韦斯特伍德本人就发起了一场这样的运动，她有一些印有“少买”字样的衬衫。我不知道她是不是在卖，但在她的推特上有一段视频，她说：“我在做这个新系列，但你们一定要帮忙，因为你们绝不能买
more or stop by less. Like don't buy clothes. That's the tricky thing. As someone who loves fashion and loves style, it's extremely hard to be like, stop buying because it's a really important form of self expression. And as you grow and as you change and as your entire body completely regenerates on a cellular level every 14 years, you need to find new ways to express yourself and the world around you is changing and the weather is changing. Like,
更多，或者说停止少买。就像不要买衣服一样。这就是棘手的地方。作为一个热爱时尚和风格的人，要说“停止购买”是极其困难的，因为这是自我表达的一种非常重要的形式。随着你的成长，随着你的改变，随着你的整个身体每14年内在细胞层面上完全再生一次，你需要找到新的方式来表达自己，你周围的世界在改变，天气也在改变。就像，
you can't not wear new things. Yeah. So how did you stop the cycle of buying and giving away and buying and giving away? Ironically, my style really paired down in the course of reporting for all of this because I was traveling so much. I lived out of a backpack and I had a uniform. I wore these black overalls on a blue shirt every day and it was extremely embarrassing because I was interviewing these fashion designers consultants, you know, and I was this unshoured mess in these clothes that I've been wearing over and over again. And I recommend everyone do this. It was like going on a fast, where I just had this one outfit. And then I got back to Oakland and suddenly looked at my now enormous
你不可能不穿新东西。是的。那么你是如何停止这种“购买-送人-购买-送人”的循环的呢？具有讽刺意味的是，在报道这一切的过程中，我的风格大大简化了，因为我旅行得太多了。我只靠一个背包生活，我有一套制服。我每天都穿着这件黑色工装裤和一件蓝色衬衫，这让我感到非常尴尬，因为我正在采访这些时尚设计师顾问，你知道，我却是一个衣冠不整、穿着反复穿过的衣服的乱蓬蓬的形象。我建议每个人都这样做。这就像是一次斋戒，我只有这一套衣服。然后我回到奥克兰，突然看着我那现在看来庞大的
seeming closet. I guess I was just so overwhelmed by the number of clothes I had. I was like, this is a wonderland. And I could just play in this forever. Oh, so you're saying that like it actually helped you not consume or buy new clothes because they were new to you. Because they were new to me and I hadn't worn them in like a month. Totally. And actually, oh, this amazing producer, Eleanor Kagan, has this great little game she likes
衣柜。我想我只是被我拥有的衣服数量给彻底压垮了。我当时想：“这简直是个仙境。我可以永远在这里面玩耍。”哦，所以你是说，这实际上有助于你不再消费或购买新衣服，因为这些衣服对你来说就像新的一样。因为它们对我来说是新的，而且我有一个月左右没穿过它们了。完全是这样。事实上，哦，这位了不起的制片人埃莉诺·卡根有一个很棒的小游戏，她喜欢
to play called the Pantone Challenge. She bought a book of Pantone Color Wheels and she'll go to her closet and try to pick out outfits based on color wheel combinations, just to help her rifle around and dig out new things. So there are all these ways of appreciating what you already have. But, you know, you, but as a thing, you're never,
玩这个游戏，叫做潘通挑战赛。她买了一本潘通色轮书，然后会走到衣柜前，试图根据色轮组合来挑选衣服，只是为了帮助自己在衣柜里翻找、挖掘出新的东西。所以有各种各样的方法来欣赏你已经拥有的东西。但是，你知道，你，但作为事物本身，你永远不会，
you will change your body changes. You change attitudes change and style is a thing. I used to have this idea. I used to think I was immune to fashion. And I used to think that fashion people, like get Vogue magazine and obey it like it's the Bible. And when Vogue says, pokedots are in, like you go out and you buy pokedots and you throw out your stripes. And that's not how fashion works. We all pay attention to fashion. But the way it manifests is not from this ruling that comes down from on high.
你会改变，你的身体会改变。你的态度会改变，风格就是这样一种东西。我以前有过这种想法。我曾以为我对时尚免疫。我过去认为时尚界的人，会买《Vogue》杂志并像听从圣经一样去遵从它。当《Vogue》说波点流行时，你就会出去买波点，然后扔掉你的条纹。时尚可不是这样运作的。我们所有人都关注时尚。但它的表现形式并非来自高高在上的统治指令。
It's just when you look in your closet and you think, I have nothing to wear. Or when you see someone wearing something new and you're like, that looks kind of interesting. I mean, even in the Hawaiian shirts episode, they were talking about how the cuts of Hawaiian shirts have changed, how the collars were pointed in the 70s and now, you know, they were like kind of boxier in the 90s and they're a little tighter now. Like, fashion's changed, they just do. And we all obey them. But the thing is, it's so easy to just scratch that it's right now, to like, see a new style and be like, I'm going to go online and just get it. And you can really easily. And this was a trap that I had kept falling into over and over again. And the person who changed my life in this regard, I went to a panel about sustainability just to do
而只是当你看着衣柜，心里想“我没有衣服穿了”，或者当你看到别人穿了一件新东西，然后你想“那看起来挺有意思的”。我是说，就连在夏威夷衫那一集里，他们也谈到夏威夷衫的剪裁是如何变化的，70年代的领子是怎么样的尖领，现在呢，你知道的，90年代它们有点像方形，而现在稍微紧身了一点。时尚变了，它们就是会变。而我们都顺从它们。但问题是，现在很容易就能满足这种冲动，比如看到一种新风格，就会想：“我要上网去买下来。”而且你真的很容易就能做到。而这就是我一次又一次陷入的陷阱。在这方面改变了我生活的那个人，我曾去参加一个关于可持续发展的座谈会，只是为了做
some research. This fashion consultant named Annie Gullingsrude. My name is Annie Gullingsrude and I'm a fashion industry consultant. And she was like, you know, look, people say stop buying. It's really hard to just quit. Instead of to shame someone, be like, stop buying. Don't even buy a way to sort of circumvent that, that I guess that addiction or that pull is to buy something that's used. There is this whole new market out there of second-hand clothes. The research is saying that we discard
一些研究。这位时尚顾问名叫安妮·古林斯鲁德。我叫安妮·古林斯鲁德，我是一名时尚产业顾问。她说：“你知道，听着，人们说‘别买了’。要直接戒掉真的很难。与其去羞辱某人，对他们说‘别买了吧’，甚至连不买也是一种方法，可以某种程度上规避那种成瘾或诱惑，那就是买二手货。”外面有一个全新的二手服装市场。研究表明，我们
before a year is up, we buy, and then before a year is up, we discard it. There's this world of like new looking clothes. It's like barely used, it's not used. They don't smell like mothballs, they don't have stains on them, and there are these websites that you can go to. Thread up, posh markets, another one.
在一年还没过去之前就把衣服扔掉了，我们买了，然后在一年还没过去之前就把它们扔掉了。这里有一个充满看起来很新的衣服的世界。它就像是几乎没穿过，它不是用过的。它们没有樟脑丸的气味，上面也没有污渍，而且有很多网站你可以去访问。ThredUP，Poshmark是另一个。
The real real is another one. You can shop on them like, as though they are new clothes. You search for your size, you can look for your color, you can look for the price range, and you can just kind of scratch that itch. That need to like scroll and look and see what's out there. Find the brands that you would typically buy, just go on the resell platforms and buy them there instead.
The RealReal是另一个。你可以在上面购物，就好像它们是新衣服一样。你可以搜索你的尺码，你可以寻找你的颜色，你可以寻找价格范围，然后你就可以满足那种渴望。那种想要滚动屏幕、浏览并看看外面有什么东西的需求。找到你通常会购买的品牌，直接去转售平台上购买它们。
When I see something that I like, I just check one of the second hand stores to see if they have it instead. And this is not a way of buying less, but it is a way of not buying any new material. And it's also a way of really interrogating what I buy instead of just impulsively clicking. It just helps me go, wait a minute,
当我看到喜欢的东西时，我就会去其中一家二手店看他们有没有。这并不是一种少买的方法，但这是一种不购买任何新材料的方法。这也是一种真正审视我所购买的东西的方法，而不是盲目地冲动点击。它只是帮我停顿一下，等一分钟，
and it helps me realize, do I really want it? If I do, let's look. And it's not even like digging through bins at the Goodwill. It's not that involved. It's one or two searches and it's helping me kind of wean myself off the habit of just impulsively buying new things. So you can begin to pair down your consumption by buying second hand and then you can also donate second hand and then that sort of creates a little bit more time between a thing being made and a thing being put into a landfill. Totally.
它帮我认识到：我真的想要它吗？如果我想要，让我们来看看。它甚至不像是在古德威尔旧货店的垃圾桶里翻找。没那么复杂。只需要一两次搜索，它就能帮我逐渐戒掉冲动购买新东西的习惯。所以你可以通过购买二手货来开始减少你的消费，然后你也可以捐赠二手货，这样就可以在物品被制造出来和物品被扔进垃圾填埋场之间创造更多的时间。完全正确。
So if you were not going to spend all your money on your clothes, what would you spend your money on if clothes. What would you spend your money on every troffman? What I always spend my money on Roman Mars. Podcasts. Yeah, you donate to the podcast that you love the most, right? Also to the podcast that I work with, I actually donate to the podcast that I work for. No, you don do. It's so sweet. But it's the best. RadioTopia is the best. Totally. And also, you know, like if you're going to, you know, go out in the world and consume thoughtfully, you should know things.
所以，如果你不打算把所有的钱都花在衣服上，你会把钱花在什么上面，如果不买衣服的话。你会把钱花在什么上面，埃弗里·特罗尔曼？我总是把钱花在什么上面呢，罗马·马斯。播客。是的，你把你最喜欢的播客捐给他们，对吧？还有我合作的播客，我实际上会捐给我为其工作的播客。不，你不会的。太甜了。但这真是太棒了。Radiotopia是最棒的。完全同意。而且，你知道，如果你要走到这个世界上并有意识地消费，你应该了解一些事情。
And that's a lot of what we do here, not just in articles of interest, but it's what we do at 99% of visible. And it's a thing that is quite virtuous. It doesn't use a lot of carbon resources. I don't know what the carbon footprint of podcasts are. That'll be interesting. It's not 8%.
这也是我们在这里做了很多的事情，不仅是在《兴趣文章》中，这也是我们在“99%隐形”中做的事情。这是一件相当高尚的事情。它不消耗大量的碳资源。我不知道播客的碳足迹是多少。那将会很有趣。它不是8%。
So whatever you would spend the next time you're on some site for buying a piece of clothing, just like say, okay, I'm not gonna buy it right now. I'm gonna take that amount of money. I'm gonna fill it in. I'm gonna go to radio say, okay, I'm not going to buy it right now. I'm going to take that amount of money. I'm going to fill it in. I'm going to go to radiotopia.fm, I'm going to hit donate button. I'm going to fill in that amount. That's a great idea.
所以无论你下次在某个网站上买一件衣服时打算花多少钱，就像这样说：“好吧，我现在不买它了。我要把这笔钱拿出来。我要把它填进去。我要去radiotopia.fm，说，好吧，我现在不买它了。我要把这笔钱拿出来。我要把它填进去。我要去radiotopia.fm，点击捐赠按钮。我要把那个金额填进去。”这真是个好主意。
And then you will save the world a little bit. You'll add more beauty and culture and cool things to the world. And also know that when we do things, the reason why we can do experiments and why we're able to grow and create new shows and create articles of interest and why we can experiment is we have this baseline of support from our listeners. So if you want to be a part of that, you can go to radiotopia.fm and click donate. Yes. And so that would be nice. All right, thanks, Avery. That's great. Thanks, Avery. Alright, thanks, Avery.
然后你就会为世界拯救一点点。你会为世界增添更多的美丽、文化和酷炫的东西。并且也要知道，当我们做事时，我们之所以能够进行实验，之所以能够成长、创造新节目、创作《兴趣文章》，以及我们之所以能够进行实验，是因为我们拥有来自听众的这种基础支持。所以如果你想成为其中的一部分，你可以去 radiotopia.fm 并点击捐赠。是的。那这就太好了。好了，谢谢埃弗里。太棒了。谢谢埃弗里。好了，谢谢埃弗里。
That's great. Thanks, Robin. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
太棒了。谢谢罗曼。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。